los últimos datos conocidos son estos
2.000 muertos civiles una cifra enorme
que han dado las autoridades ucranianas
y que un poco resume los terribles
combates de estos últimos días en
particular en las ciudades más afectadas
que son cargo mariupol
gerson también donde hoy el ejército
ruso ha tomado una para al menos una
parte de la ciudad pero también en kiev
donde ayer cinco personas murieron en el
ataque contra la torre y televisión que
dejó sin señal a la ciudad de kiev y sin
señal de la televisión por otra parte
también tenemos las primeras cifras
sobre la cantidad de personas que se
están resguardando en el metro de tiempo
que ha alcanzado la cifra de 15.000
personas también una cifra enorme que en
una ciudad que se ve casi desierta
porque la mayoría la gran parte de la
población se está
escondiendo en una aldea cercana o en el
este del país ya ha cruzado las
fronteras que tienen un gran ya con sus
países hacia el oeste
irene y qué información tiene sobre el
avance de las tropas rusas por
territorio ucraniano
las informaciones que tenemos es que
este convoy de 60 kilómetros del cual se
está hablando en los últimos días está
teniendo algunos problemas para avanzar
rápidamente hacia la capital de ucrania
sabemos que el ejército ucraniano ha
hecho volar algunos puentes y que
combates han dañado también algunas
carreteras
del norte del país que la zona que hacia
la que desde la cual se están dirigiendo
hacia quiebra y esta situación un poco
también es un resumen de la resistencia
que se está haciendo en ucrania contra
el avance de las tropas rusas una
resistencia que está integrada no sólo
por las unidades del ejército las
unidades regulares del ejercicio sino
también por unidades de civiles armados
que están custodiando día y noche en
puestos de control pero también en
posiciones estratégicas todo el país y
esto es una cosa que estamos viendo en
la calle la cantidad de puesto de
control la cantidad de sitios en los que
la gente decidió tomar las armas para
defender a este país
de cómo puede realmente